if ever there were a question as to  whether or not the mainstream media is  the trumpet for the for the left and for  the biden administration i mean you just  saw it i mean everything that biden says  they say you know the reason gas prices  are going up is because of of  ukraine it's all about the war but  americans aren't that stupid greg are  they i mean they put gas in their tanks  they know what they paid before the war  they did they are trying they're trying  to ban domestic drilling as they say  it's a putin price hike that's like  that's like kicking somebody in the head  and then blaming it on the donkey down  the road no the price hike is a  consequence of bite inflation and how do  you know that because oil isn't the only  thing going up baby food bacon furniture  bedding watches jewelry that's all going  up if it was just gas then you